[Music]
so I'd like to start out by thanking the
organizers for invitation so it's
actually fantastic workshop I think very
timely so I'm looking forward to
learning a lot so what I'd like to do
today is actually maybe make a little
bit of connection between what we heard
about yesterday and all of you today and
actually talk about our work kind of
mostly on quantum simulators using kind
of a platform of neutral atoms but I
also try to make a connection between
quantum simulators and quantum
processors because I think the boundary
between these two areas is actually kind
of gray and I think sort of you know
ideas from quantum simulators could be
extremely useful for actually really you
know quantum processing kind of general
problems and they are the way around so
here is my plan to the air today I would
like to kind of introduce a new approach
to building scalable quantum system and
particular I'll talk about work
assembling strongly in collecting matter
atoms by atoms and you know also making
these atoms interact and and in red kind
of coherent Li and the high fidelity and
then I'll use this platform to describe
realization of programmable quantum
simulator and show you how we can
actually engineer different broken
symmetries and and in study different
phase transitions and then as an
application I will talk about using the
system for probing quantum many-body
dynamics in particular I will actually
focus on kind of a very recent work you
know roving probe probe in quantum
critical behavior using the so called
cable zurich mechanism and in Outlook
I'll try to really make the connection
with this kind of you know ideas of
using this machine for for example
testing new URM quantum testing quantum
algorithms in the near term so as I
already mentioned I will be talking
about quantum
systems based on cold water of neutral
atoms and you know those systems have
you know number of key advantages first
of all they can have excellent coherence
properties for example if you think
about optical clocks is sort of one of
the you know most coherent and you know
most precise measurement devices that
man ever made and it's also easy to
create a large number of neutral atoms
so in fact you know in this room you
have a lot of atoms you know flying
around so and you know what atoms also
can be controlled this light which will
come out there's a very important thing
but at the same time you know this
neutral atom is not necessarily the kind
of obvious choice is if you really want
to build for example a quantum computer
and there are two key challenges so
first of all atoms in the gas phase in
particular intellect very weakly so and
to really you know you know connect them
where gates you need strong interactions
but in addition neutral atoms are very
hard to control individually large
numbers so for example for this example
I gave you if all of these atoms in a
room you know we just cannot keep track
of all of them right and that's why we
cannot use them as a qubits
so motivated by this consideration a
couple of years ago we started to
explore a new approach for building
large-scale quantum systems and this
approach essentially involves assembling
you know the matter atom by atom so
specifically what we do is we start with
the atomic vapor in the vacuum chamber
and we pre cool it with lasers using
conventional techniques which have been
developed over the last thirty or forty
years and then what we do is we shine
their focused beams of light these
so-called optical tweezers and what this
focused beams of light do they basically
attract atoms towards the point of
highest intensity which is basically
point of the focus and so what we do is
we focuses our beams very very tightly
so such that in each of these traps we
can have a host at most one atom two
atoms just don't fit and and then you
know we start not just with one tweezer
but we start with number of reasons like
hundred or so and just shine them all at
once and then try to load them and
and what happens is that you know this
loading is probabilistic so some of
these traps are loaded some empty so we
end up with this kind of disordered
array of atoms and so this disorder
trait has a lot of entropy so to remove
this entropy what we do is we simply
take a picture of this of these atoms
and figure out which traps are full and
which empty and then remove the empty
trap and then just rearrange the full
trap in any way we desire so at this
point we start with a regular array of
atoms all prepared in a well-defined
internal state but of course we would
like to you know do something
interesting with them for that we need
to make them interact and we actually in
my lab we explore two ways how to make
them interact one of them involves
basically photon mediated interaction
where I will basically couple these
atoms to to a special photonic system
with photonic crystal waveguide and
basically they exchange the photon
that's how they interact but today I
will actually focus in a different way
where we excite these atoms into highly
excited state the so called Rydberg
state which states with high principle
quantum number and there in those states
the atom size becomes very large and
they start basically feeling each other
and so this approach is a basis for the
collaborative project within our Center
of folder called atoms between my group
group of Markos Griner and and a group
of Latin mulege so here is just one
picture of experimental setup so the key
element of this up setup with this
device called acousto optic deflector so
basically what is device does is the
following so you shine you know a laser
beam one single laser beam into this
device and then you introduce a number
of radio frequency tones and then for
each of the stones is a cool optic kind
of modulator or deflector deflects the
beam by shot an angle and then basically
for the given number of tones what you
end up is that this beam is split into
several different components and I know
what we do is we simply just take these
components and focus it you know into
vacuum chamber with an objective and a
sex have a second objective which takes
this picture of these atoms you know
activates a feedback circle and there's
a short get sorry
and rearranges with this adamson in the
chamber as I discussed so this is kind
of a group puts a kind of relatively
small team which we started say maybe
three or so years ago so here is how
this system works
we almost in real time so what you see
here is a single short pictures of atoms
of course we have 101 atom in array and
we just take a picture what you see is
that there is a lot of disorder and then
this approach what we do is just we take
all field traps and move them to the
left and what you see is that you know
as a result you get much more ordered
array you know so there's maybe one atom
missing here but apart from that it's a
kind of perfect atomic array and of
course what we can also do is we don't
have to you know move them in this
configuration what we instead can create
these clusters of two atoms you know
clusters of ten atoms and you know once
again I would like to emphasize is a
single-shot images and you know so these
arrays are not completely perfect but
pretty good so show sample here and all
of the attempts just one atom is missing
here in all of the time just one atom is
missing but our and that actually pretty
perfect and of course we can you know
worry with the geometry of each
repetition and what contribution to look
my broken okay but now at this point the
atoms are completely classical there is
no quantum so aspect to this so to
introduce an interesting quantum aspect
to what we do is we excite them into the
lindbergh States and the Richburg states
have two special properties which are
very important for us they have long
lifetimes if you excite the atoms to the
state with large n they live for very
long time they actually cannot
spontaneously decay rapidly and they
also have strong interactions simply
because the atomic size is very large
and in particular you know for for
example for the van der Waal
interactions which we'll focus on in
this talk this interaction scales is xi
power of principal quantum number and
actually if you go to an on order of
hundred this typical there
and Rick Berg state we will excite the
interactions between these atoms of 14
orders of magnitude stronger than today
an interaction between a ground state
atoms of watch in order so we use a big
number so one can you really make a good
use of that so what in particular one
consequence of that is that you know if
you start with the atoms which are very
far away and we should try to excite
resonantly for example trying to drive
Rabi oscillations you know what will
happen is that these atoms will be exact
excited independently from each other so
these are these Rabi oscillations will
proceed independently however if you
bring the atoms close to each other than
starting from certain distance maybe
something like 10 microns or so what
will happen is that this interaction
will take over and you know will ship
doubly excited state very very far away
and so in this case if you try to excite
the atoms resonantly you simply do not
be able to excite both of them so in
this case simultaneous excitation of
atoms is block a distance is smaller
than so-called reporter blockade radius
and this will be located reduces an
order of few microns depending on which
number you are principal quantum number
you excite the atoms two so one can
actually generalize this situation to to
more than just two atoms so if you start
with a group of atoms and sample of
atoms localized to the length scale
smaller than this blockade radius and
try to excite them simultaneously what
happens is that you can be able to
excite just one atom in this cloud but
not more than one so basically
interaction between read Berg atoms in
this case will block multiple excitation
and in fact what what you end up with
you and will end up if it's effectively
like a two-level system where two
accessible levels are the state with all
atoms in the ground state and one atom
excited and of course you know if you
excite this cloud of atoms homogeneously
there will be no preference you can
excite one atom or another and you know
you will create this kind of
superposition state so the
characteristic kind of signature of that
is that you know because you have n kind
of absorbers waiting to absorb atoms so
the
the probability of excitation will
increase by n or if you want a Rabi
frequency will increase by square root
of n and this is square root of an
enhancement this kind of characteristic
signature of this dipole blockade so I
should say that this dipole pocket is
actually a relatively old idea so it's
actually I was kind of thinking about
even you know starting the experiments
like this just when I was starting at
Harvard and since but I was not
adventurous enough at the time so so but
since then it has been exploded in many
experiments for applications like many
body physics quantum information quantum
nonlinear optics so let's see if we can
combine this idea with the atom array so
in this kind of first test what we do is
just we take all of the atoms in array
and excite them homogeneously into
read-back States in this case we use
two-photon excitation but it's a kind of
a technicality so what we can do then we
can just you know prepare different
types of arrangements we prepare for
example isolated atoms item pairs or
clusters of free and just look you know
what's the dynamics and you know so in
each of this case in this case you
choose just normal or abuse relations so
in this case you also see Rabi
oscillations but you can you know even
both you have two atoms you can excite
at most one in this case we have three
atoms but still you can excite at most
one and but what you see is that a Rabi
frequency effects Rabi frequency changes
and it changes exactly with the square
root of n at least up to the point where
you hit this kind of Blockade radius R
is actually the atom the Rabi
oscillations between those ground state
atoms and the atoms will singly excite
state generally this kind of super
positions they generally entangle States
so I was already mentioned you know this
kind of ideas have been tried and
implemented in many experiments but
actually I must say that you know John
stock provides a very nice kind of
background here is that you know I will
be talking now about applying this I'd
use too many atoms but of course one has
to always remember that you know number
of atoms is just one matrix one should
also be able to do these operations with
the very high fidelity and actually this
is what the combination of Leaburg atoms
and atomic arrays allows us to do so let
me just give you one example
and this is an example of creating just
a poor atom an entangled state so in
order to do it what we do is we start
with just atom pairs separated by by you
know a large distance and just you know
excited atoms into the sweet burg state
so in this case you're supposed to
create the state Bell State
you know gr plus RG and we just need to
verify that we actually create this
state so how do we do it you know so we
first of all can just look at we make we
can measure the the state of the atom
and basically look at the probability of
atom and a ground state the probability
to have one atom excited and probability
of two atomic site then you see what you
see here is that that to atomic citation
is completely extinguished and in
addition what we need to also we need to
basically measure this face or we need
to control this face in order to do it
we simply apply the laser beam to one of
the atoms and we kind of basically uses
AC stark shift to basically shift its
levels and control the way and then you
know what happens is that this
superposition starts oscillating between
the kind of supervision with positive
sign that with a negative sign and then
afterwards after some period we just be
excited that has actually allows us to
essentially measure parity of this of
this of this state and depending on the
face you know we can really see this
parity very very nicely and from this
kind of configuration we can actually
estimate the you know fidelity of the of
the state which we measure and this
fidelity is actually pretty pretty high
so it's not you know 100% but I should
mention there here a few things so first
of all this already involves the
application of three consecutive gates
one entangling gate single atom gate and
decent aggregate and I would like to
also point out that this is an
inequality and it's actually at the
moment or main limitation is in perfect
detection so we can distinguish state
the way how we distinguish the atomic
states is that we basically we we the
excite and then we push read Berg atoms
and just you know you know detect the
state of the captured atom so this is
you know very practical very easy way to
detect the atomic state but
it's actually not you know I'm the
fidelity of that is not perfect and we
know how to fix it
we just didn't work on this you know and
what is kind of what's exciting is that
this fidelity is kind of become serious
also we can execute the gates on a kind
of hundred nanosecond time scale and
there is a ring to improve on both of
these counts and this is actually in
market contrast to to our experiments
with this platform where they'll use of
something like 80 percent has been
achieved and once again I think we have
room to improve and I will already kind
of indicate later on my talk you know
where we have this improvement but
what's most exciting is that we can
actually apply this kind of gates not
just to not impaired but on many atoms
in parallel and we with you know and we
do it with this fidelity which actually
is really kind of their work you know
this is high you know so it's not our
best case it's actually kind of an
average and a lower bound of Technology
and I'd like to indicate how you know
the application of these kind of ideas
on the example of quantum simulator so
here what we would like to do is we'd
like to implement a certain spin model
and use this model to study interesting
physics for example study quantum phase
transitions so the kind of model which
we will explore is described here so
this is an icing type speed model so it
has a term corresponding to a spin flip
the term corresponding to basically this
is like a detuning term which is like a
chemical potential so M is a number of
Richburg atoms 0 1 and this term
corresponds to the interaction so let's
kind of get this yeah
hallelujah no it can be not it no not
necessarily it can be long range in
Corrections and you'll see this now it
will be clear so that's actually in fact
you know to kind of illustrate what with
the kinds of things we can do let's look
at the zero temperature phase diagram of
this of this Hamiltonian and let's
quantify this in two different kind of
axes one will be this detuning which you
know we can we can change this chemical
potential another one will be this
interaction range is precisely the
question you or you were asking so let's
first think about that atoms are not
interacting the interactions zero so
then it's very clear that the ground
state depending on the send of the
tuning will be overall atoms in the
ground state or all atoms in the excited
state but then what we can do plug it's
a trivial kind of case but what we can
do we can now turn on the interactions
and let's now consider you know strong
interactions between nearest neighbors
only so then we can have for example
this blockade you know and then clearly
the stake like this is energetically
unfavorable but it's also clear than
what kind of state will be will be
favorable so specifically in this case
you know if you just have only nearest
neighbor blockade so you have a
constraint that you basically cannot
have two excited atoms on both states
and so in this case what you have to
kind of enter is this state which is
basically breaks due to symmetry or in
other words it's basically anti
ferromagnetic state up down up down up
down but of course we can now also
increase the interaction range you know
make interactions even stronger and
eventually the interaction will be so
strong that they block not just nearest
neighbor but second nearest neighbor so
in this case you will break the free
order you know and then you know you can
go you could keep going so this
basically is phase diagram is actually
quite rich and it turns out that this
quantum phase transitions into these
states actually very interesting they're
very distinct and you know in what
follows I will show you how we will
actually explore this phase diagram and
so the first idea will be to basically
try to enter all of these phases idea
basically so what we'll do is we
Fix interaction range start with
negative de tunings all atoms in the
ground state and then just slowly try to
enter this face so let's first focus on
the case of weak long range interaction
so the nearest neighbors are blockaded
and the interaction between the second
nearest neighbor will be much smaller
than the Rabi frequency so and in this
case so this is basically a procedure so
we turn on our laser pulse with negative
detuning
approach the zero detuning and go slowly
here and then you know basically you
know go into hopefully another faces and
just take a picture of atoms and so here
is one example of basically a few atoms
you can look now at this effect you know
what happens in different ways so one of
them you just look at single-shot images
so we started with 13 atoms in the
ground state and then by the transition
here and then what we see is that every
other atom is missing so this is just
one one-shot one image you know so
basically the missing item means it's in
the read-back state so basically
directly create is something
ferromagnetic order so we can also you
know make a bunch of these pictures and
try to do the average so we see also
some kind of anti ferromagnetic order or
what we could do is you could just
follow trajectory of all our atoms we
could just you know change the tuning
stop you know make a measurement and
what you see here is that you start
before all atoms in the ground state at
the end there is this kind of you know
anti ferromagnetic ordering merging but
in between there is this competition
between the orders I mean that's what
persons of the phase transition and you
know our kind of indicated that we can
actually program the interaction so
there are two easy ways to do it one is
just pick different grid break state for
interaction symbol is much stronger
all right or until II just bring the
atoms closer right that way you know for
a given interaction range you know you
more or more atoms will be blocked
that's what we have done here so we
basically change item separation
effectively changes interaction range so
here was this virgin atoms breaking G to
order you know if we bring the atoms a
bit closer
you know then we break the Z free order
you know NF t bring the atoms a bit
closer you know it breaks now the
see for symmetry basically what can one
can see is that you can program
interaction such a to result in kind of
desired symmetry breaking but you know
of course the question now is how well
this you know system works you know how
many errors do we make so we can of
course try to estimate it based on this
kind of two qubit a gate approach but
you know I must say that you know there
is a big difference and I think Laura D
was indicated by John between just
perfecting you know gates between just
two individual isolated qubits and then
extending this kind of perfection to a
large array so let's now try to use this
phase transition in particular in G to
state an anti ferromagnetic state as a
test how well our system works and so
for small system say seven atoms we can
just you know compare our results
directly to exact numerical simulations
kind of looking at dynamics and what you
see here is that we see actually pretty
good agreement in this case you know you
know for example this is a many body
state overlap so we start with mostly
state zero and then you know basically
go into this up-down up-down States I
must say at this point this kind of
state probability is mostly limited by
kind of our detection and infidelity but
of course we would like to increase the
system size and so when we now go to
larger and larger system what we see is
that this overlap if the ground state
decays it actually decays exponentially
but even for 51 atoms you know the
largest system that so far we have done
this experiment for you know we still
have significant like one percent
overlap so moreover if you now look you
know at the final state and you
basically look at a probability of
different microstates to a cure what you
see is that most of the states a cure I
were you know once or twice or Never
and there is one state which Lee stands
out and this is this up down up down
perfectly ordered state has the highest
probability from all of these kind of
Hilbert space to torture
probably of these particular states so
you don't you don't check the
correlations we do I was well sure you
know yes this is no mean so this is in
this case we just look for ground state
for overlap with a given state right but
we have of course all information right
we can we can measure correlations we
can you know build any kind of
correlation function so I say in this
experiment so far we only looked at Z
basis right measurement energy basis
this ground state is not even a tenth
approach it's just it's a products a
classical state right it's up down up
down up so basically so we go we start
with the state which so that's the
beauty of this you know you start with
the state that you know and you know
what the state that you should end if
everything would be perfect so in
between you have all of these
correlations entanglement and whatnot
and you see a little bit you know how it
emerges but at the end you know we know
that that's that's a way for us to
really quantify this system so actually
this and I say this is also this is a
result that we published late last year
and since the time when we're not
exactly doing nothing so we actually we
started trying to understand what limits
is 1% and actually kind of recently by
improving essentially our laser so laser
phase noise we can actually boost this
number to something like 10 percent so
what it really means is that in this
entire 51 qubit system we make this
transition and this you know the time
corresponds to something like a depth of
circuit of maybe 30 or so in the entire
array during this entire transition
we'll make on average you know maybe 1/2
errors so this kind of indicates that
it's you know we can do some you know
serious things with that but like you
know there was a question about this
correlation let's kind of look at this
same effect in a different way so let's
now look at single-shot images so
initially we have 51 atoms in the ground
state and then we make a transition and
then after the transitions sometimes we
will get this up down up down up down
perfectly other state but most of the
time this will not be like this most of
the time what we'll have we'll have a an
ordered array up down up down up
and then here is some defect and then up
down up down up down and here is some
defect so it's kind of like a classic
you know I guess it's what our
statistical physics 101 classic picture
of the kind of you know phase transition
so what we can do is we can really you
know look at these defects and these
defects are like domain walls and then
study for example how the average number
of the main walls evolve how how the
distribution of the main valves in
involve so here's you know just two and
we can actually we can have full
counting statistics for these walls the
main wall so here is just two first
moments a plot at one is a is a mean
number of the main walls and what you
see is that it smoothly changes as we go
across the phase transition from large
to small number and here is the variance
and there in speaks and this is this big
variance is precisely
you know reflects this kind of
fluctuation the system cannot decide
which state you know it chooses so
that's a point where a lot of
entanglement actually is created or
something amount is created let me just
be careful here and actually this peak
is really the the point where the phase
transition you know occurs and actually
turns out that this point of phase
transition is actually in a good
agreement with theoretical prediction by
my colleagues who besides if it's based
on a finite sized scaling for this for
this specific model so it kind of gives
you a little bit of a sense already that
we can really have some unique insights
into the into the phase transitions and
in what follows I would like to you know
just you know give you one example of
our recent work you know showing how we
can use these unique insights so
specifically so this is an application
to physics and particular to
non-equilibrium
mainly bordick quantum dynamics so so
there are two ways how we can study
these dynamics you know one of them is
we can
actually push the system you know kick
the system far away from equilibrium and
just see how this how it relaxes and and
this is one of the first experiments
what we have done on the g2 Ising type
model and actually in the very first X
and you'd say okay Ising model should
have been studied back and forth you
know by you know it's in all textbooks
but the first non-equilibrium dynamics
experiment we have done revealed already
a surprise so actually I was not sure
how long is my talk so actually kind of
you know it's a very cool story you know
but you know it's a fake it's that they
chained don't really I'm happy to talk
to you about this so basically it turns
out so basically instead what what
happens in this case when we kick the
system away from equilibrium is that
system instead of just relaxing to some
kind of formal value you know it
actually displaces kind of oscillations
which basically correspond to kind of
non monotonic entanglement growth the
atoms get entangled and then get you
some tangled and they can entangle them
get disentangled and this is you know
the curse and a state which is actually
in a for the Hamiltonian which is
technically non integrable and it turns
on you know at the time when we did this
experiment we actually did not really
know what's going on and it you know
published it and it now really
stimulated an exciting new kind of you
know frontier and many-body physics in
fact you know there is a very nice
interpretation of this effect in terms
of you know the so called quantum
many-body scars it's actually a concept
related to quantum chaos but in the
many-body generalization so it's very
cool but i'm actually not going to talk
about this so what instead i would like
to focus on is more recent study which
focuses on new idea by tech revolution
so here what we'll do we'll cross a
phase transition at a given speed and
we'll wire in a speed and we'll see how
may how many defects we create depending
on the speed which we go and what it
allows us to really do is really
probably so-called quantum critical
regime and in particular we do it using
the so called cable zurich
so this is actually work which you both
both theory and experiment is a
collaboration with with Peters dollars
and and so bill sensitive school okay so
let me just say a few words about cable
zürich mechanisms so this is a mechanism
which basically prediction on
equilibrium effects like scaling of
defects by using equilibrium critical
exponents so if you have in our system
which undergoes phase transitions or
generically you know near the phase
transition in order is some quantity
which you know diverges usually you call
it for example correlation length so as
you approach the critical point this
correlation length will diverge and
pwill diverges in a some special way so
basically as if the function of
deviation from the critical point that
will generally diverge is a kind of
power law with certain exponent it is
also another way a special feature of
the phase transition and that is that
exhibit the phase transition closes so
in particular if you talk about second
order phase transition generically the
gap will close as some power law of the
system size or you know in other words
of the of the momentum okay and so these
two quantities nu and z turns out really
can characterize the you know a kind of
universal you know features of certain
types of phase transitions so they play
very important role in the physics of
phase transition so one kind of because
this this gap closes you could also
think about in the time domain now this
closing gap means that you know if you
start to approach this phase transition
and you try to go out there basically
venturi this idea Battisti will break
down and this will result in kind of
diverging relaxation time and is the
urging relaxation time clearly D now
depends on both of these exponents so
basically the kind of experiment which
we will try to do will be the following
so we will start with in a system and as
kind of you know trivial phase and then
we'll try to go across the phase
transition with a certain speed and you
know initially we will stay in the
ground state but eventually then for
one speed you know you will you are
bound to become known as a abetik at
least for the system which is large and
what happens in these case is that if
you think about the correlation length
so and then initially the correlation
will be very short then the correlation
will start growing and will keep growing
so long as you go or do basically and
then eventually once you you no idea
Batista breaks down you know clearly
this correlation will start it will stop
growing and the idea of cables Erick
this kind of cable Zurich postulate is
that correlation length in the ordered
phase stays the same as this so-called
freeze-out point the point where you
basically stop becoming adiabatic so
that's the essence of the key Baldrick
mechanism so this cable verdict
mechanism has been explored now for
quite some time but it has been mostly
explored in the systems which are
strongly coupled to environment which
had certain finite temperature so we are
interested in the quantum kibble Zurich
prediction which should occur for
isolated system and so specifically what
we would like to do is we would like to
basically do linear sweeps occur across
the phase transition and basically
change the the rate changes slope you
know change the rate at which will sweep
across the phase transitions and
basically you know if we in a quantum
regime if our system is truly isolated
then quantum fluctuations should
dominate and basically this would
predict that the correlation length
should grow as a power law with respect
to the time that you take you know how
slow you go and the inner power there is
a combination of new in Z this is known
as a keyboard or exponent so for example
for the Ising model you know nu is
actually equal to 1 and G is equal to 1
and the skeeball Zurich mech exponent
should be 0.5 it turns out that this
actual value is very different from
what's called classical Cable Zurich
mechanism and classical cables auric
mechanism is for the systems which are
in trouble thermal equilibrium which are
coupled to the bath you know basically
they have
Damon Farmar equivalent in that case
actually turns out this value is one
short and while there has been many
experiments you know robbing these
classical cables or exponents including
in particular the gvf experiments which
were mentioned yesterday you know it
turns out that up to now this quantum
keyboard or clacking ism has not been
verified and the reason is so basically
so this you know is prediction for the
totally isolated system so you start in
a system which is isolated you know
which doesn't have any contact with a
reservoir here you start with a system
which is in contact with these are were
so you have coupling you have basically
equilibration as in so that's the
difference okay so the way how we do
these measurements is precisely by
looking at correlation functions so for
example in an affair a ferromagnetic
state we have this you know kind of
up-down up-down up-down correlations and
from there for example if you feel
exponential decay you can find the
correlation length and then what we can
do is we can basically you know just
change the ramp speed so it's important
to go linearly across the slope should
be linear but you know we can change the
reps or em speed and then basically you
know from that by plotting for example
correlation length as a function of this
sleep time we know we can indeed see
that our correlation length scales
polynomially if the sleep time with the
slope which actually is quite close to
the point five so it's actually a little
bit higher than point zero point five I
can actually maybe talk about this later
on so okay so that's kind of so that we
can usually kind of verify the skeeball
Zurich prediction but actually there is
more to that than just this one plot so
what basically you know this you know in
this kind of fury of quantum fixed phase
transitions universality is a big thing
basically what is in your sanity you
know says is that so long as you're in
this quantum critical regime so all you
know no matter basically for example
with what speed you go should have the
same result except you do this really
scaling and
what it means is that if we do this kind
of risk ailing with the speed you know
all curve should collapse on one and we
can do that so this is again this is an
envelope of this up down up down up down
up down correlation and what you see
indeed you know all of this car you know
so here is the data made before I don't
know for 10 different speeds they all
very nicely collapse but actually if you
look at this that this curve carefully
and this gray line is the exponential
envelope what you see is that something
funny is going on say actually let me
zoom it up for you so here you know even
volve all of this you know data points
collapse to each other they clearly
deviate from the exponential and
actually in fact the correlation become
negative kind of very puzzled initially
and but it turns out that there has been
some predictions of these effect and
really it shows that this keyboard rig
picture is a kind of easel is a right
picture but it's only kind of very
coarse-grained picture so once you start
looking closely what you see is that you
know like there is some you know
correlations between the main walls
which are developing so these
correlations are actually likely due to
the interactions between the defects and
what's most important is that this kind
of result cannot be explained by just a
formal state so basically what you do is
you go here you create a kind of non
thermal State so okay I mean we are sort
of still in the beginning of exploring
that but already you can see that we can
really study these systems at a very
kind of new it is sort of I would say
somewhat even unprecedented level of of
accuracy
so let's now having understood this
transition let's try to see what happens
with these other transitions is a
transistor can be exotic so in
particular one way you could do it is
that you can change interaction strength
and then you know plot for example just
a Fourier transform of this kind of
other parameters here
the momentum is 0.5 which is corresponds
to the z2 States or then you know if you
increase the interaction strength
eventually you end up with the
if the period close to one third you
know and here is you know maybe in the
period of one fourth emerging slowly
there are also this transition points so
it's basically shows you this a little
bit this phase diagram is not so simple
maybe yes it appears from the fourth
glads so and in actually indeed it is
not simple so in particular this
transitions into Z three states have can
be a different character depending where
you cross it and moreover in between
these phases there is this other phase
which is called in commensurate phase
where basically these different orders
complete and one thing you know I don't
want to go too much into details but
just kind of you want to give you a
little bit of a taste one of these kind
of interesting domains here is a
response to a so called chiral clock
model which actually another kind of
paradigmatic model of condensed matter
physics which actually was a Pidgey
thesis of David Hughes you know and you
know studied for for many many years so
basically this is associated with this
transition to G free phase and you know
the kind of intuition here is the
following so G phrase if Reggie three
phases in other state every third site
is occupied so in a kind of clock it
corresponds to error pointing up but
then what can happen is that you can
have two types of domain walls you know
can I will have a domain wall where one
of these items shifted to the left so
it's like going one direction or it can
be shifted to the right which clogs go
in the other direction and actually
transition to this chiral clock model it
turns out to be very special very exotic
and actually in particular it
transported is described by the by the
field theory which does not have G
equals to one it's actually very unusual
so it's not a relativistic field theory
so okay so we can just try to measure
these cables work exponent by going into
this state and what we see here is the
plot of this extracted cable Zorich
exponents are basically two lines one
can draw one is this izing line and what
I already indicated is actually you know
our data are lie
somewhat above mostly this kind of value
corresponding to 0.5 and there is also
this another plateau which corresponds
to this chiral clock model and actually
you know to Galvis to be really try to
kind of push the envelope on the Furion
that we have flew numerix mps and finite
size scaling we get now the number for
this quadratic model which is an pretty
good agreement so there is also this
deep and this deep you know we believe
really corresponds to this and
commensurate phase where basically you
know orders can it so basically what we
already see is that we can extract
critical exponents for different
transitions we have some agreement with
with numerix but this really pushes the
state of the art of numerical simulation
and what's also important we see effect
of this long-range interaction
particular this deep is due to
long-range interaction also the fact
that this value is a bath point one
looks like it's an indication of
long-range interaction so okay so what
you see now is that we can now use our
simulator as a kind of precision tool
for studying quantum critical phenomena
so what do want to do with that clearly
we have a lot of work ahead of us would
like to extend it to 2g improve
coherence I would like to start probing
entanglement so it turns out that some
of these models which we realize have
really some interesting topological
properties so for example you can
realize a bi-national onions but what i
would like to really do now in this last
you know few minutes is make a
connection to the subject of the
workshop to the you know kind of
near-term quantum algorithms so in
particular it turns out that our model
pretty much directly implements a very
important class of of problems known as
a maximum independent set so what is
maximum independent set so suppose you
have a undirected graph where vertices
are connected by the links and basically
you know an independent set is a set of
this colored vortex is such that you
know no two connected vertices are
colored at the same time so this is for
example an independent set and this is
another independent set
when basically you know the means
problem is very simple just for given
graph you know find the largest
independent set so it turns out for this
graph this is the largest independent
set this is a maximum independent set
but in general this is actually a very
hard problem so it's actually an P the
problem itself is np-hard even in
general finding an approximate solution
is also np-complete but what I'd like to
do here is I'd like to actually look at
one specific example of this miss and
this will be this Miss on the unit disk
graph so basically this is an example
shown here so where we have all of these
vertices and they are connected so long
as to what this is are within a certain
distance there are two things I would
like to say about this so first of all
you know this kind of you know graph
should you know look familiar to you for
example in the back of your airline
magazine you know you have example of
this kind network so at X it turns out
that this problem is an important
problem and moreover it is still and
p-complete even for this you need these
graphs you know so now if you followed
what I've said previously about
describing the street but blockade and
all of these ideas and you know what you
will realize is that this kind of
problem the solution of this problem is
nothing but this ground state of this
read blockade Hamiltonian we're
basically blockade reduce is simply this
D right you'd like to excite as many
items as possible but you cannot excite
more than one so it provides a really
kind of a starting point for us to think
about what we can do and you know
certainly one can now think about I were
using a job I to color it more perhaps
you know applying kind of sequences of
pulse gates of the kind that I also
outlined we can maybe think about
implementing qu a so we have now start
started to think you know a little bit
how we actually implement it so
something that I'm happy to talk to you
but kind of an interest of time let me
just conclude by showing that you know
this problem becomes very interesting
once we go to 2d arrays and this is here
we're now starting to trap atoms in two
dimensions creating some arrays of atoms
and starting to rearrange
them and I think this really is a very
exciting frontier where no Benny body
physics you know a quantum control and
quantum optimization can really you know
work together to do something special so
I think I've used up my time so I hope I
gave you a little bit of a feeling about
the state of the art of the earth in the
news page specific area so maybe the
only thing that you know I must say here
you know is that you know quantum
information is now of course very
exciting field and you know quantum
computing in particular but what's kind
of ironic is that you know we don't know
how to really build truly large-scale
quantum computers at the moment and we
also don't know even if we build them we
don't know what they can be used for but
what my hope is that with these recent
developments we are now on a verge of
building systems which are large enough
coherent enough and programmable enough
that we can really start finding out and
that's where maybe interactions between
our communities could be particularly
beneficial thank you very much
[Applause]
so so we have not characterized this
yeah but but so if you're a giclee so it
looks like for example both is you know
examples of dynamics kind of you know
far from equilibrium dynamics and the
one which in this keyboard or it can be
generally described by kind of matrix
product states
so of course close to quantum phase
transition you have to kind of push the
bond dimension high but even generally
these are these are matrix I think at
the end they can be described very well
by the matrix product state so so in
this case of this I know far from
equilibrium dynamic dynamics it turns
out quite amazingly is that these kind
of these observations you know which we
observe can be described by matrix
product state or to the leading order by
matter exploding state of of one
dimension to so and this is actually
where this kind of connection with
quantum scars really you know becomes
relevant so these are states with kind
of very minimal amount of entanglement
where which we are basically with
entanglement you know does not really
grow very rapidly so of course you know
if we if we wait for a long time then we
can no longer use it
exactly exactly exactly and this is kind
of very very interesting so I mean I can
you know chew show you a little bit what
is
so the the interesting so that's kind of
the interesting results the result
involving this this quantum scar
discussion so
so basically entanglement images I'll
show maybe the result of some
simulations too
this is one example now it's a
simulation for 25 atoms and it's already
one had to do some tricks to do these
numerix because it's a constrained
Hamiltonian which actually which sort of
once we observed was read experimental
observations who try to make sense of
them and what you see here is when one
one does this kind of rapid quenches it
turns out that you know depending on the
state you our have you know we're kind
of rapid decay of these oscillations and
kind of very rapid growth of
entanglement or alternatively you have
these kind of postulations which are
just really for very long time and they
could respond okay this is maybe a quant
so here is an entanglement er P of half
of the chain but you know what you see
here this for this constrained commute
onion this entanglement grows very very
slowly right and but if you look I mean
if you look at individual sort of pairs
what you see is that it was too late so
you create low content and it comes back
you know so there are certainly very
interesting entanglement structures
which in the origin this and this in the
systems and actually what is kind of
also pretty special is we have ways to
measure them you know and we have not
done it yet but this is something that
we
so thankful save questions for
discussion in the afternoon
[Applause]